Take Ivermectin. Do you take the calculated daily dose all at once or divided?
I looked up the half-life for Ivermectin and it's 18 hours.
So
the half-life is 18 hours, then it's you still have half of it in your system at 18 hours.
That's a very long half-life.
Considering the resveratrol has a half-life of about five minutes.
So when you take 100 milligrams of resveratrol, assuming that you absorbed 100 milligrams for a
sake of argument here. In five minutes, you only have 50 milligrams left in your system.
Literally, it goes by that fast. That's why you need to be taking it throughout the day. That's why
all your flavonoids and things when you're taking clear inflame for your brain, you want to
break it up into pieces through the day and any other supplements that even don't have a long
half-life. 18 hour half-life is a very long half-life. So taking it all at once would be just fine.